[Musik]
es droht Stromknappheit und es droht
außerdem die gross Klimakatastrophe
ermögliche Lösung Atomstrom mit einem
solchen Pellet schaffst du es eine
Schweizer Familie ein Jahr lang mit
Energie zu versorgen wir können Energie
produziert keine CO2 im Betrieb er hat
die kleinste landbedarf für die
Reportage frage ich mich ins Innere von
Kernkraftwerk
ist der Neubau
[Musik]
ich schnappe mir mein E-Scooter und
anderem auch mit Atomstrom aufgeladen
worden ist meine erste Station ist AKW
göske
2016 Schweizer und Schweizer
[Musik]
Projekt vor der Angst vor der nukleare
Katastrophe vor der Angst AKWs setzt
wenig sicher drum will ich mir selber
das Bild machen
ich wird vom Herbert Meinecke bereits
erwartet
er wirkt für mich sehr offen bitte
Migration
ich bin Ingenieur ich finde es
eigentlich eher schön sowas und was da
oben rauskommt sind so so zwei bis drei
Badewannen Wasser pro Sekunde genau
ist das Wasser verschwendet also das was
da oben rauskommt geht natürlich in die
Atmosphäre und macht Wolken das ist ja
klar und damit ist es nicht verschwendet
sondern immer noch in der Atmosphäre
irgendwo wird es wieder abregnen
[Musik]
jetzt Gottes Reaktorgebäude übers Anlage
wird mit dem Herbert nicht im Detail
reden es beginnt sie nicht Zuständigkeit
für mich ist es aber wichtig das Thema
nützliche
[Musik]
Unterwäsche ehrlich gesagt bin
überrascht dass der Anzug nicht dicker
ist wenn es von der Film kenne und das
Dosimeter da oben rein zusätzliche
[Musik]
also wenn wirklich an einem geöffneten
radioaktiven System gearbeitet wird dann
hat man andere andere Sachen an also so
wie mit fremd belüfteten Anzügen und so
weiter so ein bisschen wie bei Simpsons
über Simpsons ja das ist so eine erste
kontaktbildung für Sie mit der mit
Kernkraftwerk und dann hat man halt
vielleicht falsches Bild veranker
gewesen das ist tatsächlich so ja ich
habe habe Elektrotechnik studiert und es
war mir überhaupt nicht klar wie wie
doll in so einem Kernkraftwerk wenn man
da in der Nähe vom Reaktor ist wie stark
ist der strahlt das wusste ich damals
noch nicht
[Musik]
die Luft wird überwacht dann ganz ganz
vielen Stellen das ist so ein
radioaktivitätsmonitor ich habe dir ja
gesagt Radioaktivität kann man ganz ganz
leicht messen und der misst jetzt also
die die Luft die wir hier atmen auf
Alpha Beta und Partikel genau gucken wir
mal nach ob der Reaktor noch da ist Gott
zum Radioaktivität und Sicherheit bei
AKWs dann kommt mir sofort der Unfalls
Sternenbild im Jahr 1986
Seite wäre in der Schweiz nicht passiert
und du kannst dich wahrscheinlich noch
an die Bilder erinnern wieder in
Fukushima so das Dach wegflog und das
war ja eine Wasserstoffexplosion keine
Kernexplosion und gegen Wasserstoff
haben wir solche Sachen da drin das
heißt dass ich hier in dem Bereich wo
Wasserstoff sein könnte und vielleicht
explodieren könnte kann gar kein
Wasserstoff sein das was das angerichtet
wird gelernt hat ist Fukushima die
andere schon ewig gehabt ja aber sie
hatten es nicht und das ist immer die
Frage wie sicher ist ein Kernkraftwerk
und das ist so sicher wie die
Gesellschaft die ein Kernkraftwerk
betreibt das haben möchte und wir in der
Schweiz wir sind ja sehr heikel mit
unserem Land und wir nehmen sehr sehr
hoch mit der Sicherheit und darum haben
wir hier sichere Kernkraftwerke
Sicherheits vielleicht anders so auch
vor starke Erdbeben oder Flugzeugabsturz
auf der achtergebäudet AKWs in die
Schweiz gewappnet das wird der Unfall
also muss vielleicht mal die Idee
Gemeinden drumherum Fragen die Leute die
da wohnen haben da keine Angst
ich habe den Eindruck Angst haben den
haben er die Leute die es nicht kennen
die die nicht nicht nah dran waren wie
lange könnte man jetzt ohne sie ohne
dass man einfache Problem hättet ihr
könnt mir hier wohnen aber es ist ein
bisschen warm oder nein du kannst jetzt
hier ein ganzes Jahr du willst keinen
keinen Schaden nehmen
Brennelemente angucken wäre auch noch
was da siehst du so die hellen da das
sind neue die kommen dann im nächsten
Jahr mal rein in den Reaktor und dann
gibt's ein paar dunklere also mehrere
dunkle sind dann schon benutzte die auch
noch mal in den Einsatz kommen
also benutzte bedeutet dass man das Uran
mehrmals in mehrere Stufen kann Spalten
also ein Brennelement hat etwa fünf
Jahre im Kern an fünf verschiedenen
Positionen
und danach ist es ist das spaltbare
Uhren ausgebrauch aufgebraucht und dann
wird es durch ein neues ersetzt wir sind
jetzt da relativ nah und du strahlst
immer noch nicht und dein Dosimeter hat
das schon gepiept nein das noch nicht
steht immer noch 0
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
durch Brennstab Recycling das sogenannte
widerrufbereitungsverfahren ich habe in
der Schweiz die 2006 verboten will es
unwirtschaftlich und
umweltgefährdendsten Brennelement sind
noch 90% Rohstoffe und nur 10% Müll also
man könnte die Müllmenge reduzieren wenn
man wollte also Mangel reduzieren
wenig aber das Plutonium würden wir
wieder benutzen und Spalten dann wäre
das Plutonium weg
strahlt das Plutonium noch für 24000
Jahre radioaktiv und wird Ihnen
[Musik]
wie viel durch wie viele Türen
noch im einstündiger Rundgang misst man
Dosimeter ein microsive während du mit
12stündigen Flug von Zürich auf New York
retour nimmt man ludbundesamt für
Strahlenschutz ca 100
[Musik]
produziere
Atomstrom braucht im Vergleich 100.000
mal weniger Ausgangsmaterial als das
Kohlekraftwerk das sind die das sind
dann die uranpellets drin und da die
Dinger sind in diesem Brennstäben
bisschen höheren drin mit einem solchen
Pellet schaffst du es eine Schweizer
Familie ein Jahr lang mit Energie zu
versorgen und zwar mit der gesamten
Energie
standhütt wird es gibt bis 2039 im
Betrieb bleiben er potenzielle
Verlängerung
nach dem Besuch für dich persönlich
beruhigt in der Nähe vom AKW goes
gewonnen mir schient Sicherheit und der
Strahlen oberste Priorität anders sieht
aber hat mir Katastrophe wie Tschernobyl
und fukus
überhaupt könnte nachhaltig sind solange
sie radioaktive Abfall produzieren
momentan
[Musik]
vor rund 50 Jahren gibt es Menschen wo
gegen Atomenergie kämpfen
über 15.000 Personen demonstrierten
gestern in Kaiseraugst gegen das
geplante Atomkraftwerk und für eine
sofortige Einstellung der Bauarbeiten
diesen großen bevölkerungsaufmarsch bei
strömendem Regen und eisiger Kälte
hatten nicht einmal die Organisatoren
erwartet Leute aus allen Schichten und
allen Altersgruppen waren es vor allem
Leute aus der Region und viele aus dem
angrenzenden Deutschland und Frankreich
welche durch ihre Teilnahme die
Forderungen der Redner unterstützen
heute
können wir unser Recht zurück und weil
wir in Notwehr handeln müssen
übertreten wird dazu auch Gesetze Teil
für den Betrag ist der Peter Scholler
womit der Gruppe nie wieder Atomstrom
Hypno gegen Kernkraft kämpft glauben
[Musik]
so
zusammen fahren
die beiden Aktivisten in zivilem UKS
er würdige
Wertegang als Baumeister hätte ich
durchgeführt dass als ich am Anfang sehr
für Atomenergie gestanden
friedliche Nutzung und das im Baustellen
Baustelle
Abfall ist das
sit Date setzte Peter privat und
beruflich Allrad auf erneuerbare Energie
und kämpft zusammen mit dem Ruedi gegen
Atomstrom
und das ist das Gebiet wenn ihr 11
Wochen lang
[Musik]
Schaft stark gewachsen bis Schweizer und
Schweizerinnen
von damals
und keine Energie was
was ist das für euch ist das Hobby Lied
es schafft
Leben und vor allem wir können
politische
Geschichte
und vor allem zeigt sich als würde auf
dem richtigen Weg
und das immer stolz
[Musik]
der Nationalrat hat es neue
Energiegesetze unter anderem werdet
zukünftig Alpini Solaranlagen gefördert
die mit dem Winter mehr Solarstrom kann
erzeugt werden
Greenpeace Activision
schon zusammen mit Wasserkraft der
tiefste CO2 Fußabdruck hat wenn ich
jetzt vertraute
aber ich glaube es hat sich mehr so
Organ als wenn man in der Schweiz sich
für Klimagerechtigkeit engagiert dann
auch immer wieder die AKWs in Quere
schienenlösung
sämtliche realistische zeige die sind
Wedel wirtschaftlich neue effizient und
vor allem in dieser
Klimaabkommen
Technologie du bist der Gedanke dass man
solarhemmt
ich bin Augen getechnologie und ich
finde es genau ich finde es noch
gefährlicher wenn eine Technologie war
für mich
nicht zukunftsfähig ist auch nur einer
entgegen
für Atomstrom zum wird die Notwendigkeit
hart zum solarenergiewind und
wasserausbau
der Planet und Physikbuch zum Klimakrise
innere vernünftige Zeit
aber ja zum das springt der solarspringt
in Bezug auf schweizen im trennen
umsetzen
zur bezieht sich übrigens auf der Studie
wo Greenpeace in auftragge hat lud den
bricht ist in der Schweiz zukünftig
möglich trotzdem AKW-Ausstieg auf
Fossilien
[Musik]
wo das anders sieht AKW Befürworter in
Analyse manera
Professorin und Expertin für Herren
Energie wir haben schon vorab
telefoniert und sind Trump
für sie ist klar ohne AKWs
sie erklärt mir vorab die aktuelle
Kernkraftwerke der Schweiz
aquavis wo punkto Nachhaltigkeit in
Schritt voraus so wird die der
radioaktive Abfall nur wenige hundert
Jahre Strahlen also nicht länger als zum
Beispiel der radioaktive Chemie Abfall
im Spital EU hat ja gesagt dass
Kernkraft euch das Atomstrom grün ist
als grüne Technologie
keine CO2-Emissionen haben oder sehr
niedriges CO2-Emissionen haben dass wir
eine sehr kleine landbedarf haben dass
wir sehr kleine
Bedarf von Materialien haben und und
kleine Menge an Abfall produzieren oder
gibt da keine Energiequelle die die Null
Erfolg produziert wenn man diese
Elemente nimmt dann kann man sicher
sagen dass so dass die können Energie
zum zu ein Teil von die Lösung ist aber
wenn Abfall ja mehrere Millionen Jahre
zum Abbauen
sind nachhaltig aber wir müssen also
alles ist es relativ oder also die die
anderen Energiequelle produzieren
die muss man auch
ich denke es ist irgendwie schade dass
die erneuerbare und die können Energie
gegenüber gespielt werden weil wir
brauchen eigentlich alles um und und
beides um eine CO2-frei
energieproduktionen zu erstellen die
Schweiz aus das große Vorteil die seine
eigene
Stromerzeugung ist schon jetzt CO2-frei
weil es ist dann meistens von von
Wasserkraft und können Energie
produziert Problem ist du was machen wir
wann wann unsere Werken abstellen müssen
so das bedeutet dass wenn wir ein EPA
zum Beispiel also ein Contra Werken
ersetzen wollen wir brauchen 500 dafür
solche Anlagen also 500 Photovoltaik
Anlage also 500 von diese von die größte
Solar
Kraftwerke die in der Schweiz gebaut
so das ist nicht nur ein Panel oder sie
ist nicht 500 Panel also wir sprechen
von Millionen und Millionen Millionen
von Solarpanel
wenn ich gerade Dimensionen denke wie
viel Solarpanel
ob das realistisch ist ich bin ehrlich
gesagt und Deutschland möchte bis an die
vor dem Jahr der Atomausstieg umsetzen
zumindest
und nuklear-expertin Annalisa haben im
Interview verzählt dass sie das ein
großer Fehler findet und ehrlich gesagt
habe ich der Gedanke selber auch schon
überraschenderweise teilt die minigalt
Greta Thunberg sie hat mit der Aussage
Deutschland zu bestehen die AKWs nicht
abschalten und AKWs sind besser als
Kohlekraftwerk für Schlagzeilen
und konfrontiere sie damit über
Deutschland müssen wir noch schnell
reden Deutschland was meinet ist
Deutschland zu voreilig ausgestiegen
aber so eine Übergangsphase jetzt
Deutschland hat ist das nicht viel
schneller schädlicher fürs
klimaschutzend
mit den mit dem Ausstieg bis die
erneuerbare Energie sowie sind darf ich
froh das wird sich zeigen das wird man
hier einen auch wissen
wir
Technologie moderne AKWs können wir
nicht fahren
aber die Technologie ist nicht super und
wenn ich natürlich
die Baue aber das AKW mit der verborgen
erstens gibt es keine das ist ein großes
Geschrei das wird der hui treffen
Schweiz
das macht jetzt hallo wach also ich
hoffe
[Musik]
nach einer den entsprechenden
fasziniert vor deinem modernen AKWs wo
jetzt in der USA gebaut werdet und
weniger radioaktiven Müll würde
generieren auf der anderen Seite
verstehen die Megas Argument von der
Gegner und Gegnerinnen
aber was meinet ihr zum Thema Willi
Lösung